um
hi uh so uh welcome to chartbeat again
uh my name is harry wolf uh i am a
front-end engineer here uh working on uh
our dashboards and our
applications across the
sharpie
sites um my talk today is uh from
closure to angular uh a journey between
frameworks
um
quite
yeah so uh in the beginning in the
beginning uh charpie uh was using um
google closure library um
uh it was in case you don't know what
google closure is um it's a
suite of uh
it's a javascript library that
is a
thin wrapper around native dom apis that
normalizes all of them
and makes sure that when you're writing
some code it works across all browsers
it's very low level um
but
so it doesn't like to really do that
much for you
this is what powered all of charby's
dashboards when we were first getting
off the ground
so
it worked very well for us for a long
time but it did have a few problems um
for when it was a little slow because it
was so low level you had to do a lot of
the
heavy lifting of dom manipulation
yourself i'm actually going into saying
you know make this display block make
this like with 300 px like whatever we
had to do was very manual
and because of that it didn't let us
sprint as fast as we wanted to like as a
startup you have to be able to build as
quickly and as ugly as as possible to
make things work uh which google closure
was not the most friendly with um
another problem that we had with the
community um so inside of google uh
sorry yes just to be clear you're
talking about slow as in time to market
not slow in terms of performance
absolutely correct um in terms of
performance it's excellent because it is
so low levels you have very granular
controls over uh what's going on in the
dawn um
not s
the same is true with angular but i'll
get into that more yeah if there was any
questions please just
yell
not too loudly but just
audibly um so i think that was the
problem with the google closure was the
community it's very big inside of google
but outside of google it's not that well
known
so that was a problem because
for a few reasons
that
created some friction for us
because
two main points of friction one it was
very hard to find a google closure
engineer in the wild except from google
which is also hard to get as well
but also because
it's also not that hip i guess like a
better word like nobody like wants to
learn google closure because if you're
not in google you don't
care
um
so what to do so just to give you a
little background sharpie works in six
week cycles we work on our product for
six weeks and then in the seventh week
we have a hack week where we kind of
just get to play with something that we
don't normally get to mess around with
um so uh in this instance when we had
this problem like what to do to like fix
this issue that we were having with
google closure we figured that we should
do uh something a little different for
this hack week we decided to do a
javascript framework shootout
great
thank you i made it myself
so for the javascript framework shootout
um pretty much the rules were every
front-end uh engineer uh chose a jobs
framework um and went off into the wild
and started uh developing a demo that we
could then uh get back after the week
and talk about and see what we
what we found um so
some of the frameworks that we like
investigated was you know backbone um
investigated at ember um
surprisingly we also investigated
angular
that
um so
can you guess who won
anyway yeah that's a hard question um
so yeah so english is the next
generation yes um so when we started
with angular we got the chance to like
start afresh um we got to just pretty
much just wipe the slate clean because
it was just a whole unique
infrastructure luckily we had the uh
luxury of doing so that there was new
products on the horizon that allowed us
to not
uh worry about backwards compatibility
so we could actually literally just
start fresh and take what we've learned
in the past and then adapt it for the
future
um
some of the things that we thought about
was
so when sharpie started off we had one
dashboard we had like one just like
real-time analytics dashboard that could
tell for your site what was going on
that was fine that was how we structured
our code uh today sharpie has
like
multiple product verticals we have the
publishing uh
product and we also have the advertising
product um and just the amount of things
that we do is more so the question is
how do we structure the code
that is beneficial and helpful in
development
does that make
sense um
so we have to figure out how to make
this application structure scale so um
we came up with a solution uh it's been
working with us uh pretty well so far um
it's
yeah pretty well so far it's been
working um so to give you an idea this
is actually like if you go into our
github repo uh and look in front into
the front end folder wanted ng literally
for
uh next generation but also for angular
it's a nice little like anything you
want to talk to you can change the
meaning um you shouldn't name things by
its name it's bad practice um but so
yeah so in the front strategy director
you have here you know the advertising
product the sharpie publishing cdp
publishing product this common directory
i'm going to talk about a little bit
more in a second labs marketing open
source i'm going to talk about uh at the
end um
so what we actually ended up doing was
yes
uh this is actually like prune like
there was there's like a node modules
directory in there power components that
was distracting so i took a screenshot
and like
yeah
a developer photoshop which is nice it
was good
thank you thank you yeah just career in
mind stuff no um so um what we actually
ended up doing was modeling um our
directory structure in the way in which
chirpy works um so we actually work in
like cross-functional teams like we have
a
publishing team we have an ads team um
and we actually made the code structure
reflect that so there was less friction
as we actually developed
um
and now it's been working really well so
far we also have this idea of the common
directory um so
any company that you work at you will
have code that is shared especially as
you get bigger and you have multiple
teams working uh
uh basing like just alongside in
parallel
um
you're not gonna be able to communicate
as much but you still want to be able to
share code that is common to build those
teams
and that's what we've done with a common
directory for example we have
a thing we call the feed service which
is how we make api calls and that's a
simple wrapper around the http service
in angular
um pretty much
that's sweet um
all right so
pretty much in the column directory is
any code that is shared across all
products
and this is on a product level
um any questions so far
good uh so now to delve a little bit
deeper let's open up the advertising
directory so like in the advertising
product directory we have multiple
applications or dashboards um so we have
like no campaign
all these other types of dashboards and
in here you'll notice we also have a
common folder as well what we've done
here is that within a individual team
there is some code that is shared
amongst that team but not necessarily
between products
that's just the way that we've seen
things shake out
if there ever was the case that there
was a piece of code that was being used
by the ads team that alice on the
publishing team needed to use as well
we'd physically take that code and move
it into the upper into the higher root
level column directory so it could
actually physically represent the way in
which it was used um this allows for
just intuitive usage of the code and the
layout of things um
yeah so that's about that so now it's
actually delve into an individual
application let's open up a common
uh campaign directory
this is where it gets really fun uh so
like if i was to make my own like my own
website like
as a just a fun thing to try out this is
pretty much how i would lay out my code
it's been working out pretty well for me
uh for all of us um
so you can see here we have skull file
we're using gulp
come on in
no worries glad you came
um
so uh in the room of the director we
have a gulp fall we're using gulp um as
our build process we're gonna talk about
that a little bit more later
my buddy jem is going to be talking
about i don't know where
where is he oh he's behind the pole all
right
um so yeah so john will be talking a
little bit more about how we use gulp
but um every individual application at
sharpie has its own individual
gulp file to represent that it is like
if one day we wanted to separate these
into separate repos we could because
they are uh aside from the common stuff
but i'll talk about that a little bit
later um
they're all
self-contained um so you have the gold
file package.json you have fuse
uh tests and styles those the views are
partials that you use with like ng
include to make sure you don't have like
one huge file that has all the code ever
that you'd want to use ever which would
just make your eyes bleed over from
reading like 2 000 lines of code in one
file
um so we also have the test folder which
uh
our styles no they're tests they're
actually the best
just to confuse people um no so we have
tests and styles and then
so that's the uh associated files so
what's interesting where it gets a
little bit interesting is here with uh
components in js so uh in researching
the best way to layout our code we came
across two concepts of styles for laying
out your code one called by type another
by pod
excuse me
um the idea is that so by type is
literally by type of the file so like
you have you know all your controllers
in one folder all your directors one
folder etc
by pod is grouping your files by uh the
function by the uh functionality that it
provides for example if you have like a
tooltip uh component that would be one
pod that would contain you know the js
file which is the directive the style
sheet the less vial and the
template as well all one directory um
so we actually went with a kind of
hybrid approach
where we have uh
the components directory which uses the
pod file system um and then also the js
directory which uses the type file
system so
literally the only thing that
differentiates where
when you should then opt into the pod
system is a component is anything that
requires more than one file
for its function for it to function
properly
like as i was saying a tool tip you need
the directive file for it to function
just functionality but it also requires
the styles for it to actually be laid
out correctly on the dom
at that point you're up to two files
automatically it should go into the
components directory no questions asked
just how it should be done
um
so that's the majors that we have then
also in the js directory we have
controllers director services filters
when there is a need for a filter
specific to
a dashboard
and we also have this app.js file which
is how you do this is where we declare
an angular module
we have one module per product
and we also have the raspberry file
which
defines
the routes
thankfully
did other things you'd be very confused
um
so that's kind of how we're structuring
each of our dashboards like that's what
powers the charity publishing dashboard
the labs
the labs page the big board
they're all mirrored the same way
and like if you're in the campaign
dashboard you can then use the
com the files in the common directory
relevant to
uh ads but also to the front end g at
large
and allows you to then just keep the
scope there
any questions
there
sounds good makes sense good idea bad
idea
an idea yeah that's really common code
um
you said you guys are out there and put
it in a higher directory
how do you make sure like dependencies
are
like something doesn't break let's say
somebody else is like using
a
like there's an api dependency right and
then you need to break and change so
does everybody want to change their api
so there's no version that we have
internally um there is the awareness so
that's what the benefit of having a file
in a common directory does is that when
you are modifying a file in there you
innately know that there are
uh like let's say you're modifying it
because like the thing you're working on
like needs that change because it's in
the comment directory you know that
other files are depending upon that so
you have to then go and like you know
test those other things as well uh it's
you know reliance on our front engineers
to make sure that we don't screw each
other over um but there's no like for
just versioning that we have
um but yeah uh
dubbing a little bit more most of our
common uh common files declare
themselves as their own modules
as opposed to like so we have like you
know adds dot campaign as the module
name um for features that is its own
module name
do you make these modules uh modules as
well
i'm gonna get into that in the next
section
within
each module
yeah so i should have included a
screenshot but like for the tooltip
directory in that tooltip director we
have
uh cb tooltip.js cb tooltip dot less
we're using less
cd tooltip.html all in that same
directory
yeah it's a little boilerplate like
we're like you have to like copy hello
welcome
um it's a little boilerplate but you
have to like you know add the html to
the js file and select the uh the main
template to include the js file and then
put the left stuff um that's something
cool that like polymer is doing like
they're allowing me to package them all
into one file
which angular doesn't have yet but
for now it's just by just you know
convention grouping those files
we don't need it ultimately
i've used require.js in the past
it requires a lot of forethought into
your architecture to figure out where
the appropriate places are for lazy
loading um and with the luxury that all
of our stuff are dashboards mostly um we
don't have to worry about there being
um
you want to worry about the weight of
the code so we can just kind of just
like dump it all into the dom and then
just let it go
and in terms of like in the building
system that jem is going to be talking
about that a little bit more how we
actually get this stuff onto production
so i'm not gonna step on his toes is he
angry yeah
yeah one last section and i'll be done
um
so another thing we're trying to do with
turkey is open source some stuff
yay open sourcing i slammed it anyways i
said it wasn't going to um so yeah we're
trying to open source our things uh
we're trying to get back to the
community and we're trying to you know
share because sharing is caring and we
care a lot
um so
so but the thing the problem is that
we're actually finishing a couple of
hurdles um things that we didn't really
realize would be
uh
painful once we tried to open source
things uh the first thing that we didn't
realize is that it's kind of a
full-fledged product making an open
source thing um you actually like it
takes time it's like a lot of work
especially like disregarding the fact
that we didn't develop with that in mind
or had the luxury of like keeping two
things in mind at the same time
but to actually like have somebody go
through and like uh take code that is in
an existing product and make it
working not only for that product but
also like in a way that anybody else
could benefit from
takes time it's work um so the thing
that so like the way that we were trying
to open source is you know we're trying
to first you know
uh
as i was saying like abstract that code
like we have the cd tooltip like it's
working in our products but there's
certain aspects of that tool tip that
may not be applicable towards the
community at large um and that's another
thing that takes time is identifying
where that line should be drawn from
where you should open source the
component or just be like that's too
like sharpie specific and like that's
not worth the effort
um
what's nice about the abstraction part
with angular is that because of the way
that it does directives it
encourages isolation of behavior
so that the cv tooltip because it's a
directive and like you use it in the dom
you know exactly where it's being used
so you can actually like you know figure
out what you need to do to actually get
it out of that code base which is nice
that angular helps with
the other thing that uh we actually have
to do is physically move the code out of
those directories into uh a new open
source directory that we have
um and we have as you were saying like
we can't break things that depend upon
that
and the hardest thing that we've been
facing which is
still debating about the best way to go
about this if any experience please do
talk to me afterwards because welcome
ideas opinions whatever um is how to
sync the code
which so
once we have all this code ready to be
open source we're going to move it into
its own repository uh publish it
publicly on github
but still then use that code in our
applications and the question is
how do we
create as little friction as possible
for us to like to digest that code but
also to develop that code in parallel
if there's any added friction into the
process we're not going to be as
encouraged to support that code we'll
start just making our own internal codes
again to get the whole purpose of open
sourcing anything
um
so that's
it's hard
so
some of the ideas that we've had some of
the mechanisms that we've had for
actually figuring out how to sync this
code is
npm
bower
sub module and subtree
we're not we're leaning more towards the
get methods
in particular sub module as uh painful
as it can be at times um
we're still weighing the options we need
to investigate subtree a little bit more
to see if that would be a little bit
less painful um but
um
yeah it's a work in progress but we were
making
progress uh so this is the open source
directory as it currently exists uh it
is a wip work in progress
a lot of progress um but so
uh if you're not we uh hope to actually
have this out in the public as soon as
possible i have no estimates to give you
that's uh as we have time to do but uh
definitely a priority of my own to do
it's mostly directives so like we one of
the things that we're very well known
for is our dial that you saw when nathan
was giving his introduction to open
source that um our cv tooltips is very
well done uh nick developed that and
implemented the amazon way of hovering i
don't know you guys ever read about how
they uh create an algorithm that allows
for you to hover over an object but then
also do it at an angle so it's not just
like bright lines but it's more natural
yeah so
a lot of how you lifting there which is
really awesome hope i'm not speaking
that
um so we're hoping to open source that
as well um
literally anything that we use that we
think has an application that like if i
was to work on my own code i want to use
it as well
because one of the sad things is like
when you go from company company you
just make this great thing in there and
you're like well i can't
use that
um so yeah
where's my mouse
um but yeah that's all for me thank you
so much